this is a production of Cornell  University  well we bought it a drone for our field  research program this year it's it's  been very helpful for us to be able to  see our studies from the air a lot of  times you you can see things that you  wouldn't notice so readily or at all  from the ground so it's been very useful  one of the other nice things about it is  for interested parties you can't make it  to the site we can send them photos with  pot plans so they can see treatment  differences for themselves it's very  simple to operate you can set it for two  take photos at any interval you like  have it set to take whatever photo every  five seconds and you can also do video  this has been a production of Cornell  University on the web at Cornell edu